Speaker 1: We are continuing to very closely
look at the December six Georgia runoff between
incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael Warnock
and challenging Republican candidate Herschel
Walker. Now, we've already talked about how
Herschel Walker has no business being senator
from Georgia. I'm going to give you yet another
example of that a little bit later on in the show.
But one of the interesting questions has been,
is Donald Trump going to show up to try to help
Herschel Walker? Barack Obama is showing up to
try to help Raphael Warnock now that we know and
he will be campaigning with him. But Donald Trump
has is apparently so toxic at this point in time
that Republicans are trying to keep him as far
away from Georgia and as far away from Herschel
Walker as possible. New York Times Reports Trump
Plans Limited Role In Georgia Senate Runoff. The
former president, who held two big rallies before
the state's two runoff elections two years ago,
both of which Democrats won, will steer clear of
Georgia before next week's Senate election. And
when you look at why, you very quickly understand
it. Michael Bender writes for The New York Times
Donald Trump will not cross the Florida state
line to campaign with Herschel Walker during
the final week of the Georgia Senate runoff
election. After both camps decided, the former
president's appearance carried more political
risks than rewards. Campaign officials for the two
Republicans said Monday. Do we believe that Trump
was sitting there going, You know what, it's true.
I've become such a ticking time bomb and a hothead
and liability that it's probably best that I not
go. Probably not. It's probably the people around
Trump who got together with those running Walker's
campaign and said, We're going to try to keep them
away. Trump is planning a call with supporters and
will continue sending online fundraising pleas
for Walker. Now those online fundraising pleas
default to 90% of the money actually going to
Trump. And here is sort of the key line of the
article. The decision to keep Trump out of the
spotlight was a response largely to the former
president's political style and image, which can
energize his core supporters, but also motivate
Democratic voters and turn off significant
segments of moderate Republicans. One other really
interesting element of this in Georgia, that
political math has become a net deficit for Trump.
That's a critical line. Who opened his 2024
presidential. Campaign two weeks ago. In 2020,
he was the first Republican presidential candidate
to lose the state in 28 years. Earlier this year,
his handpicked primary challengers, Governor Brian
Kemp and Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger,
were both trounced. This is more
interesting in terms of 2024. Now,
I don't want to diminish the importance of
getting that 51st Senate seat in Georgia.
The data is looking pretty good for Raphael
Warnock. We never count our chickens before
they hatch. We never you know, you use whatever
metaphor you want. That is an election we have
to fight for. We're going to be covering it,
including up to the live results on December six.
But there's another component to this, which is
what is Trump's path to victory in 2024? And what
I mean by that is if you start with the 2020 map
and you say, what was marginal here? You certainly
look at Georgia. Now, the problem with that math
is flipping Georgia alone from 2020 won't give
Trump the presidency. So you need Georgia and
something else or you got to flip Pennsylvania.
Georgia's increasingly looking bad for Trump. And
part of that signal is exactly what's happening
in Georgia right now. So when we think about
can Trump win? And listen, I was one of the
guys that a week before the 2016 election said,
I think Hillary's got it in the bag and I was
wrong. So I am not going to fall for this again,
particularly two years early and say, oh, Trump
has no path to victory in 2024. The difference
is we've seen what a Trump map looks like.
And Georgia is an important part of that map.
Georgia's an important signal when we think about
2024. And Georgia is looking so bad for Trump,
that is being kept away when it comes to Herschel
Walker. That's why it's so critically important
right now. Let me know what you see as Trump's map
and path to victory there. And maybe we'll even
do it. We're not going to do maps between now and
November of 2024, but maybe we'll do one sample
map to sort of look at what it could be. Send me
your thoughts. Make sure that you are subscribed
on YouTube. Make sure that you are following us on
Facebook at Facebook.com The David Pakman Show.
Much new content coming. The white paper on how
to talk politics without ruining relationships is
now available at David Pakman dot com slash guide.
A thousand people have already downloaded
this. I am stunned. We were thinking, well,
if 250 people download this thing, it's
probably a good start. A thousand people
have already downloaded this guide. It is
free at David Pakman dot com slash guide.